[Musique]
ma chérie bon âge qu'est ce que tu fais
comme ça l'a tous fait laver arrête je
lis à la bougie je commence à m'habituer
le candidat du npa et pour la sortie du
nucléaire
alors s'il passe à temps sortie du
nucléaire ça veut pas dire revenir à la
bougie
ah bon bah écoute philippe poutou il va
t'expliquer lui comment sortir du
nucléaire en dix ans bien sûr que c'est
possible
ceux qui disent que non nous raconte des
mensonges comment on fait et en disant
comme le propose le npa
je vais vous le dire en propose trois
choses économies d'énergie développement
des énergies renouvelables création de
centaines de milliers d'emplois au npa
on a un plan argumenté et chiffré qui
s'appuie déjà sur tous les progrès
scientifiques de ces dernières années en
france on consomme environ 500
térawattheures par an en électricité en
propose déjà d'en économiser un quart en
disant c'est facile il faut remplacer le
chauffage électrique économiser sur
l'éclairage public supprimer les
panneaux de publicité lumineux imposer
des normes sur le froid mieux isoler les
locaux et bien d'autres mesures encore
et est ce que c'est possible bien sûr
les japonais n'ont plus qu'un seul
réacteur qui fonctionne sur les 54 qui
étaient en service avant fukushima et
ils viennent d'économiser 15% de
consommation en une seule année
et on n'a pas entendu dire que les
importations de bougies ont grimpé en
flèche au japon alors les économies
c'est une chose mais ça ne suffit pas
ensuite il faut développer les énergies
renouvelables
et là encore on a un plan détaillé on
est d'ailleurs les seuls on propose par
exemple de produire 15 % de notre
consommation actuelle
rien qu'avec les éoliennes terrestres
c'est facile à atteindre en dix ans et
avec un rythme normal
tous les calculs sont dans notre
scénario et on propose comme ça de
produire avec le solaire les éoliennes
marines et qu'on ne vienne pas nous dire
qu'il n'ya pas toujours du vent ou du
soleil on sait parfaitement aujourd'hui
stocker l'électricité éviter
l'intermittence contrairement à ce qu'on
nous raconte edf le fait déjà il suffit
d'investir dans les moyens de stockage
et tout ça ça coûtera beaucoup moins
cher que de construire de nouveaux
réacteurs upr et ça créera des centaines
et des centaines de milliers d'emplois
toutes les études sérieuses le prouve
quant aux travailleurs du nucléaire
aucun de perdre à son travail au
contraire car ils pourront choisir soit
se reconvertir dans les énergies
renouvelables soit de participer sur
place au démantèlement des centrales et
à la gestion des déchets pendant des
décennies et des décennies
sortir du nucléaire en dix ans non
seulement c'est possible mais c'est
nécessaire pour éviter le risque de
fukushima français pour nous ceux qui
veulent garder le nucléaire sont tous
des irresponsables mais au npa on n'est
pas fou même si c'est possible du point
de vue scientifique
on sait très bien qu'on n'arrivera pas
comme ça à le mettre en oeuvre tant que
ce seront les capitalistes et le profit
qu'ils dirigeront la société c'est pour
ça que ce qu'on propose en premier c'est
un monopole public de l'énergie
j'irai par les salariés et par les
usagers en propose d'exproprier total et
les grands groupes de l'énergie qui font
la loi contre toute l'humanité alors si
vous voulez vous battre pour notre
planète contre le nucléaire avec le npa
et toutes les associations
antinucléaires ces élections ne
suffiront pas il faudra manifester pour
leur reprendre le pouvoir
mais en attendant un vote pour le npa le
seul parti vraiment anti nucléaire et
bien ce serait un encouragement fort
pour tous ceux qui veulent lutter pour
tous ceux qui espèrent en une autre
société débarrassée du nucléaire
[Musique]